yeah because you gotta talk to three
Filipinos two Indians and then you get
to someone and one of their names is
yeah like sir I understand your
frustration
[Music]
did you guys do anything for your
five-year wedding anniversary nope our
five-year wedding anniversary we don't
really celebrate our wedding anniversary
yeah we do we like hold hands and look
into each other's eyes that sounds real
oh you guys do tantric what
yeah we do do you have a ceremony do we
Bart do we have a ceremony no we just
exchange we exchanged a few sentences do
you guys like [__] all the way into the
night no not at all well then I guess
you guys don't have a ceremony no but we
exchange we exchange romantic sentences
give me give me the last one you told me
but it's like I'm still down
I'm still down I'm down if you're down
I'm very happy to live this life with
you and you make my life better than it
has ever been but look at her eyes okay
yeah he was looking away though I feel
like I'm in the way I was trying to
remember what's one of your romantic
sentences I remember what I said shut
the [__] up give me a kiss oh yeah
it was going like this way and then like
this the perfect alley-oop for the dunk
I bet Geo has to be like take those
pants off Big Boy she'll say that to you
why are you gonna back up into the
corner because
I just are usually off she tells me to
take my shirt off yeah because the pants
are already off because Bart walked out
in the house with his dick dangling out
where you could see just the [__]
coming out of the T-shirt like this what
well the AC vents are from the top so he
gets a little bit cold
see but my legs are hot yeah so this
story is about a California couple that
had their five year wedding anniversary
and they decided to take a vacation to
Guatemala oh wow it's very beautiful
yeah you like that yeah that's more your
type of thing huh going to [__] weird
places no it's not my thing didn't you
El Salvador yeah just because it's like
my wife's family is from there oh so it
wasn't because you appreciate the
culture or anything like you hated it
what are they known for pupusas yeah
okay just poo poo what are they known
for here
so uh they took an Uber while they were
in Guatemala right the Uber was supposed
to cost 55 dollars
I mean it tells you doesn't it yeah yeah
already a detective so seriously yeah
yeah dude I don't trust any of the [__]
that comes out of your mouth how much
how much do you think they got charged
uh 55 you're saying where Guatemala uh
it's supposed to be 55 USD through the
app or through the verbal through the
app else
2500 nope five bucks five thousand five
million
almost lower than that forty thousand
thirty thousand dollars what so at the
end of the trip they're like this can't
be yeah so they finished the Uber ride
he looks at his he he looks at his uh
balance because he's trying to buy
something and his shit's getting denied
for insufficient funds it wiped out
their joint account it took thirty
thousand and held it and then he
contacted Uber and Uber was blaming the
bank what and then he called the bank
and of course back and forth yeah the
racket ping pong you've been that person
before yeah
it had their debit connected to their
Uber account I guess yes imagine being
overseas though and then your funds
getting Frozen that's scary you can't
even buy a plane ticket oh like what the
[__] that's exactly what was happening
they were unable to buy anything and
they couldn't resolve this issue because
both sides were blaming each other they
didn't get the money unfrozen for four
days don't you have like more than one
credit card though if that was like
their debit and they actually lost your
money and there's still like a line of
credit they're like none of us wish like
yeah yeah Anthony you piece of [__] poor
people have credit cards that's how they
stay poor but they're all maxed out dude
are they gonna make fun of poor people
they have 200 left just because you're
rich don't look down on us but [__]
Anthony keeps [__] making fun of poor
people in a bad decision I can't believe
you not everyone has overseas yulin
accounts
you were acting like this before you
went to China what changed man Nick back
me up you know what no I can't right
we're over we're fine it's me dude you
guys are like celebrating your
anniversary right now we're tired of it
that's how they bond is they just try to
dunk on Anthony and try to get Anthony
on something it's been easy to get real
rich with the 40 pay cut but this is
this is a good start this is a good
start let's let's talk about ways that
they could have avoided this you're
saying just have multiple cards I'm just
assuming that even if you won it's dumb
to put your debit card connected wow you
don't stop I do think that's dumb that
is dumb though that's so mean
credit card
okay this guy's pretty good bad even
even if you go to the local gas station
you know these are debit that you can
get uh tell my mom that [__] okay what
if they're like my mom wanted to talk to
your mom yeah
I just think that's smarter you should
use credits there's more protections
that are put in place for consumers
that's why you have credit is it better
to use credit cards speaking as somebody
that's worked in a bank 100 man because
it's it's you should tell your mom no I
do no no she's hooked up but she's
hooked up it's crazy how many people
don't have that knowledge though there's
a lot of people that don't understand I
don't know about now but at least when I
was working at the bank uh a lot of
people didn't understand the concept of
how credit cards work I'm like what the
[__] well a lot of people don't want the
feeling of debt either
just out of safety though when a credit
card you get identity theft or whatever
it's not your money that's being taken
away yet and you can deal with the you
know whatever
it up to a certain amount too for your
credit so it's like you're way more
protected as a consumer but when it's
your debit they just take the money out
of your account and you [__] are
gonna be like oh my God I can't pay my
bill
don't people use [__] Saran Wrap and
[__] excuse me okay like so with their
the so you have you don't use your debit
card right because it's direct access
to the [__] rest of bag of chips yeah
when you eat chips you don't get the
whole bag just dump it all out and eat
three of them up I put the rest of it
back in you siphon it out right so
that's what the like why would you want
why would you use the theme that has
direct access to your life savings use a
credit card because then that's like
dumping it out and then Saran wrapping
the rest of it huh I don't know if
that's a great one but I'm who eats like
that you eat like that yeah tell them
dude I open the bag and I go directly
see that's what normal people tell me do
that with your money I just think the
concept of Devon credit if you're gonna
use a bag of chips it's like a direct
ice to your bag of chips but if you use
credit it's almost like there's somebody
else brought a bag of chips of the same
flavor you get to eat that and then when
you know that you just replace it see
that's even smarter
well you just got a direct compliment
yeah that's even smarter yeah that's a
great analysis the point is relish the
moment I know I know thank you it's not
gonna last long please clip that
[Laughter]
when I was like 18 or 19 like I was like
no [__] [__] why would I use my debit
card directly if it has direct you also
didn't have money either I know but I
don't want no one stealing my 32 dollars
sure that's precious yeah true is
Frito-Lay fun
over
steal your [__] card information now
from ATMs to like all that yeah how much
is dangerous have all of you guys had
overdrafted accounts oh yeah but really
absolutely you never did
no I have always had money
but we were doing okay he's gonna
overdrafted crypto accounts
first first year or two of JK
uh we're working out of the the house
the front house it was probably
overdraft every other week oh [__] every
other week it would be like and we
started being able to time it we're like
okay if you over if it's overdraft now
we that means we can still get a Costco
pizza and pump gas before they block it
but then that's perfect because then
AdSense will come so it's like oh my God
it was like always negative back to zero
negative back to zero 35 charge every
time yeah worth it and then if you do
overdraft protection where you can't use
your card because you don't want to get
overdrafted you just get denied at the
[__] Pride those now
I don't think I ever know what that
feels like what a baller he just
explained that you guys went through
that together no read it oh you got it
it well and then other and then the
second thing once you get over the idea
of debt or the fear of debt with a
credit card because you're paying it
every month you're paying a balance
Number One You're Building credit number
two you're getting Reward Points because
you're spending that money anyway if
you're using your debit card you don't
earn reward points on it you're just
spending straight your account what
about someone who's like well I'm afraid
of the interest rate
that's why you pay off your balance
every month but what if they don't want
to pay off their balance then have fun
baby
drinks on you get that 400 FICO score
base is there any type of counter
argument to this because it sounds like
it is pretty common sense to yeah
in the US too we have such good deals on
credit card and what I mean right yeah
cash back and like points like a lot of
other countries don't do this because I
think people just know that like so many
people are more undisciplined than
disciplined yeah so like that's the only
counter if you don't have the discipline
but if you know how to use it yeah like
every year there's a card that's zero
percent APR and that you can transfer
your debt from this one to that one you
can keep rolling it over the interest
rate doesn't kick in until a year and a
half so if you just have a little bit of
knowledge and a little bit of impulse
control you can have a lot of protection
around your finance and also what
happens is
um when you're if you don't give your
credit cards a heads up that you're
going to be spending outside of the
country yeah if they're super sensitive
with stuff like that then they will just
block it at the first transaction yeah
so it could have happened where like
they swipe it for a Friday but then the
offices are closed Saturday Sunday and
then Monday rolls around I mean there's
but nine out of ten times they'll send
you a text right away yeah a text or an
email why are you always trying to piss
on My Parade
I just learned this the hard way they
must have a lot of cash because that
means they just have 30 Grand in their
account oh it's in their joint account
yeah and it's and it's like wiped
wouldn't that bank actually like alert
you of Fraud and overdraft fees and all
that stuff too if that's supposed to get
a 30 000 charge on yeah it says that
that's kind of the amount that they had
oh so they took like 30 000 and 20 22
cents or some [__] to the point where
they thought like somebody had like
hacked and cleaned them out or something
because it was so exact but let's say
that you work at the bank and this
happens to someone that's a party back
they called you and they were like 30
000 of you [__] serious what's your
like response how do you like deal with
that uh that they think I like I I'm I
have the authority to do something about
it yeah they're saying it because it's a
bank error and they're like you don't go
too bad so sad like help me that's a
good one uh I would help I'd be like
well first I have to see who took the
Monday who authorized the transaction
and uh logically it makes sense that
Uber allowed that transaction to go
through so the numbers like no it was
you guys
no I would talk I would probably spend
my time talking to Uber and being like
okay how the [__] do we sort the [__]
out yeah going back and forth with them
and this type of thing could take four
days like for sure because now they have
to look at transactions they have to
like these bigger companies there's just
so many Hoops that you have to jump
through like there's this department for
this thing and this department doesn't
communicate with that department so like
instead of them talking directly now you
have to like be the middleman between
the two like it's so convoluted and like
she said if it's [__] Friday 4 55 p.m
Eastern Standard Time you know what I
mean like you're right yeah because you
got to talk to three Filipinos two
Indians and then you get to someone and
one of their names is Francine
Francine dude yeah like sir I understand
your frustration uh especially we are
doing everything we can to solve your
situation and then it's really bad and
then and then if you're you have The
Misfortune of speaking to someone that
doesn't operate with common sense like
I've learned now because which is 80 of
the time yeah I've had to talk to so
many customers service people that I've
learned that if that person can't
understand what I'm saying within the
first 10 seconds I'm like okay I hang up
you meet I don't even try to just hang
up and I try again it's kind of like a
lottery here like a roulette huh I was
at a bank uh two weeks ago or three
weeks ago and then I was like I was
handling some like finish up some stuff
from my dad and I was like oh okay can
we move this money here and I'm also I'd
like to close his account and then he's
just like oh why I was like because I
said he's dead I'm like he's not going
to be using this account and she's like
are you sure oh my Lord are you
listening to the words I'm saying
[__] I'm like he's dead he's not
gonna be like oh I need to [__] put
my Netflix on this car yeah did you
spell it out for her yeah I was like man
you guys are crazy did you act it out
yeah no did you go
yeah
if you acted it out I think she would
like okay she's like I feel like there's
on such autopilot that they don't
[__] think yeah I'm like he's not no
one's gonna be using this account by the
name of Paul call center people like
that's not American they got really good
like from five years ago because before
they would just read the paragraphs that
they were given and you know those call
center folks they do more than one
business oh so that's why they're like
yeah they might be doing Verizon Chase
all of them at once because then when
they get a line from Chase yeah they're
like reading a [__] script and then
they're going like oh I understand your
frustration sir thank you very much for
your patience and it's like dude you
don't have to say 30 seconds worth of
[__] to answer one thing I hate when I
do that it bums me out but I guess they
have to Charter Communications has never
upgraded their staff though I'm telling
you right now ATT Spectrum two Spectrum
can eat a whole bag of dicks dude
[Music]
foreign